Is Facebook about to unveil an Android-based phone?
So goes the speculation on tech blogs...
...sparked by a press event the company just scheduled for April 4.
Dubbed "Come See Our New Home on Android",
...the event has been pegged by a Techcrunch source...
...as the launch of an HTC handset with a distinctly Facebook twist.
The new device may feature an altered Android operating system...
...with deep Facebook integration,...
...including a mobile home screen driven by Facebook services and apps.
The rumored name is Facebook Home,...
...and it could bring an end to years of whispers about Facebook's mobile intentions.
Alas, for like, happy, true believers...
...the result appears to be more of a phone inundated with Facebook...
...than the mythic Facebook phone.